the Joe Rogan experience where do you
think all this social justice outrage
goes do you think it's it dies off what
people realize how ridiculous it is and
it becomes like bell-bottom jeans dude I
think it's all caused by the internet by
these echo chambers you live in yeah and
these algorithms that should want you
being angry yeah I think it's making
everybody angry about it's the same
fervor as the blue dress gold dress it's
on one of these things now and it's the
same fervor like this was too dirty
before it's like was it's too
race-related this is too misogynist
whatever it's just like people turn on
each other on a level of like why you
guys would sit next to each other at a
ballgame and have a good time
everybody's pretty [ __ ] nice to each
other most people most people want get
that [ __ ] Edward out of my way I mean
you just never see those people anymore
right so it's like are we just looking
for someone to attack so in the Bible in
the Torah there's this med rush there's
like a fable of so got to choose to
choose this what they taught us in
yeshiva to choose the Jews it's unfair
to have us as the chosen people right
it's unfair to the other cultures so
there's this fable that says God tried
every other culture let them live their
entire existence and then they died out
they killed each other off never got to
the Messiah age and then died out so one
time he picked the Christians one time
he picked the Chinese one time he picked
the [ __ ] Norwegians one time you pick
the Germans as his like this is my race
right and every time it didn't work out
and one time in one of these things and
they said maybe that's where the
dinosaurs are he gave them the world for
a while and there didn't work yeah but
yeah it's like yeah you guys are kind of
reaching you could just say whatever but
they're trying to explain it away cuz I
got no explanation for dinosaurs but
anyway well they said it used to be
where crops just grew and animals were
just abundant and you know one had to
toil and so the mankind would toil and
then didn't have to everything just grew
right so they would think that maybe
this would be easier to be nicer there's
this guy who has his theory on like
since computers are gonna come up we're
not going to need like 40 hours of work
week anymore probably 20 and his theory
I forget his name is that with those
other 20 hours we'll read more we'll do
crazy things but I don't think it is
because in this fable of Judaism when
and didn't have the toil they just went
to war they just started murdering each
other hmm because you need conflict so
in great time is it wearing right now
where everybody's doing well a knife
won't cost a lot of money and almost
nobody hat doesn't have one right we're
doing great we're in an opulent Society
racism is down to super low levels but
you need someone to attack so even when
you're in a bubble of LA to New York and
almost everybody is 95% on your side
you're like I need to attack somebody
because everything's too easy so it's a
sign of how great we are I think that's
accurate I think that's definitely
what's going on and that they don't
there's not real problems I go war real
real like hard hard crime and the
violence in the streets and so we're
looking for things to be upset at I also
think there's a lot of people that I
have access to their phone whether at
work and I think their board is [ __ ] I
think there's a urology up and there's a
lot of wasted time if you were an
employer and you're paying someone to do
stuff by the hour I guarantee you most
of their time spent listening to
podcasts watching youtube videos and
talking [ __ ] on Twitter getting what's
making angry
[Applause]